Eugenio Derbez in controversy for revealing that
he prefers to help puppies rather than children.
Eugenio Derbez is one of the who have been committed to the fight
against animal abuse and in new statements the actor revealed why he
prefers to support this cause instead of children or in vulnerable situations.
During 2023 the actor lost his beloved dog Fiona.
Despite the difficult loss faced by the actor,
he is still very committed to helping abused or stray dogs.
In a recent meeting with the press,
Eugenio Derbez talked about the gift his daughter gave him in honor of Fiona.
He indicated that it was very emotional.
In this regard,
the actor talked about the importance that his dog had in his life,
which is why he is still committed to helping street dogs.
The actor has been workingst in relation to animals since he was 16 years old,
but has never made it public due to the attacks he usually receives.
The people who attack because you don't rescue children from the
and because you don't rescue the blind children and you say wait
for me I'm helping the dogs You help whoever you love the most," he said.
As was to be expected,
his statementsed controversy and there
have been many who have been against him.
However,
most of his fans applaud his work.